superhero workouts for superhero actors
what else could we expect we've got the
secrets behind how these actors dieted
worked out and fully committed to
bringing their physical shape to the
next level ready to be inspired let's go
number one robert pattinson said he
wasn't working out for it but seeing
just how buff he is in the movie we know
that was far from the truth pattinson
may have joked about slacking but he did
anything but there was a tough training
regime that included everything from
boxing weight training bodyweight
workouts to military style sandbag
workouts on sandy beaches oh and we
can't forget about those three to six
mile runs he'd go on four times a week
now all this seems pretty normal to
prepare for a part like this but one
workout was a bit out of place all the
superman holds he was doing every single
day
number two early cat gets the bird zoe
kravitz was smart and opted to head to
london a few weeks before filming
started to get into a workout groove
with the trainer three months of
training beforehand and then you have to
keep it up the actress was pushing her
limits working out unbelievably hard and
she was seeing the results i became very
very strong i was able to do more
push-ups than i'd ever done in my life
and i could lift heavy things and carry
heavy things it was absolutely crazy to
feel the physical transformation once
filming did start the actress didn't
stop her work making sure she was in
peak condition for the whole shoot you
literally just film and train that's the
only thing that we did
number three it's the magic number once
you pass over the six week mark then
then it's all right after a month and a
half of working hard pattinson was
starting to feel like himself seeing
stellar results taking on a full
physical transformation as well feels
even more exciting the first part of the
experience wasn't so great but
eventually it turned around and boosted
the actors confidence
number four you gotta learn to work the
feline way kravitz wasn't just looking
to get into good physical shape the goal
here was catwoman the actress knew it
would be a complex process obviously you
want to look good in all that and feel
good but i wanted to make sure that it
was possible for her to do any of the
physical things that i was doing to make
it happen kravitz and stunt coordinator
rob alonso spent the early days of their
time together watching videos of
domestic and wild cats trying to break
down the ways they fought and moved all
this info was used to inspire the way
kravitz moves as catwoman and as
interesting as it was it was a major
challenge for the actress
number five eat clean stay lean no
matter how you put it once pattinson
wrapped he was very over eating a clean
and usually boring diet the one food he
hoped he'd never see again boiled fish
no it's true no processed meats fried
foods and very limited alcohol intake
was the name of the game the clean
protein-filled diet wasn't the worst
part though the days that pattinson was
going shirtless he did anything to look
as fit as possible including severely
limiting consuming anything at all even
water pattinson just stuck to counting
sips of water a tool typically used by
bodybuilders and amateur wrestlers
number six who is the man behind the
prosthetics colin farrell has never been
more unrecognizable but the prosthetics
did make him look stunningly strong and
meaningful according to the actor
himself when he signed on for the gig
farrell wasn't in the loop about the
fact that pretty much every part of his
face was going to be hidden by
prosthetics but it did help him get into
character the first time getting into
his penguin prosthetics took 4 hours so
he had plenty of time to dig into his
penguin vibes
number 7 to work out or not to work out
by the time he wrapped his first film as
the dark knight pattinson was fitter
than he'd ever been and he was finally
enjoying his workouts and newfound
lifestyle after coming this far and
getting through the hard part once
patinson knew it would be much easier to
just keep up his routine so he'd never
have to go through the hard bit again
but it didn't really play out that way
as soon as the job's not like no as soon
as he wasn't becoming batman every day
he wasn't working out to keep in tough
physical condition anymore either
number eight the people want what they
want when ben affleck signed on to play
the dark knight he knew audiences would
be expecting a certain level of fitness
so in turn he knew to expect putting his
absolute all into his prep both
emotionally and physically seems all
right but the tricky part was keeping
his age in mind those joints gotta stay
intact strength training was key for him
especially since wearing the batman suit
meant he'd be carrying around a casual
extra 70 pounds affleck overachieved
during his prep for batman vs superman
gaining over 30 pounds and looking slick
as can be weighing in with only 7.7 body
fat he was so fit he actually had to
lose about seven pounds before filming
number nine this guy is shockingly good
at losing and gaining weight christian
bale is known for his wild physical
transformations and prepping for the
dark knight was no exception this bulk
up was kind of insane we're talking a
hundred pounds of muscle how did he even
do it working out every single day
focusing on all the different muscle
groups he needed to work on and when it
came to food it was lean protein healthy
fats and carbs all day every day if he
was feeling like a treat low calorie
fruit and a big glass of water could
always do the trick
number 10 we need some hot packs asap
tom hardy was bulking up hard to play
bane not only was he working out every
day he was doing it four times a day
it's no surprise that with that kind of
training he gained a solid 30 pounds of
muscle and mass it wasn't the best of
experiences in the long run though at
the time hardy explained i think you'd
pay the price with any drastic physical
changes the fact that he was in his 40s
played a big part in the difficulty he
really just had to be much more careful
about how intensely his body was
transforming because well it just wasn't
what it used to be and those aches and
clicking joints became a very real
concern
number 11. what a woman batman vs
superman introduced us to the always
impressive gal gadot as wonder woman but
before she graced our screens the
actress took on an intense physical
workout regime and built up her skills
like nobody's business she did the usual
things clean eating intense workouts
cardio marathons but then she leveled up
we're talking jiu jitsu sword fighting
and kung fu combine that with the gallon
of water she was drinking every day and
you've got a recipe for a wonder of a
woman
number 12. sticking to it is the hardest
part but amy adams was ready when the
actress signed on to play lois lane she
knew her co-stars were going to be
working out hard so she joined in on the
fun when she got into the routine she
found herself on a total role and stayed
fit for all the batman movies she was in
putting in extra effort right before
filming would start of course while her
workouts weren't as intense they were
frequent as she found so much benefit
from them it increases the serotonin so
i find i'm a happier person when i work
out more patient for sure if it works
you better work it number 13. it works
but it costs batman vs superman saw
everyone bringing their a game
especially henry cavill suiting up as
superman everyone has their own way of
getting there but for cavill it was
eating the cleanest meals he could find
that is until he said bye bye to a whole
lot of calories closer to the start of
filming the superman diet isn't fun but
it's definitely effective
number 14 consistency is key henry
cavill was working out non-stop building
muscle mass and strength olympic
weightlifting movements were one of the
major contributors to all those gains
calvel didn't just rely on all the work
he'd done once filming started though
over the course of the 120 day shoot the
actor had the elite trainer mark twight
by his side to keep him in tip-top
condition every single day
number 15 from woman to catwoman to
become as agile and sleek as a catwoman
anne hathaway knew she would need some
help it was about being able to do the
stunts and the fighting perfectly she
brought on personal nutritionist jackie
keller to help with her diet it's all
the boring stuff that no one ever wants
to do hathaway was already in pretty
good shape but toning up was key for her
getting into the role she said it
herself it was a complete transformation
complete transformation is right these
actors really tested their limits and
considering the results it was well
worth it
whose workout routine do you think was
the toughest